[Music]
breaking news this tuesday night
canada's sweeping new travel
restrictions
the measures arriving at airports as the
omicron variant spreads travel rules and
border rolls in particular can always
change
rejecting the mandate to vaccinate it is
disappointing the thousands of
provincial employees shooting down the
shot
b.c can't catch a break as another
atmospheric river rolls in it's like is
this going to keep happening the
province's record-breaking rainfall
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
as the holiday season approaches and
people plan to travel abroad there are
new hurdles to overcome canada is
introducing new rules for travelers
because of the potential threat from the
new variant omicron anyone entering the
country by air even those who are fully
vaccinated will now need to do a pcr
test on arrival and self-isolate until
they get a negative result the only
exception is people flying from the
united states the time frame for this is
not clear the public safety minister
admits it will take time for airports to
organize and it may be expanded to land
borders
we are also working quickly with
provinces and territories to determine
how we could expand testing capacity to
include all travelers from all countries
including the united states from both
land and air
if needed
in the future
as well three new countries have been
added to the list of nations from which
travelers are banned nigeria malawi and
egypt canadians or those with the right
of entry to canada who have been in
those countries must quarantine and be
tested on day one and day eight
the new measures are part of canada's
rapidly evolving strategy to contain the
spread of the omacrom variant its
emergence last week has prompted the
return of border closures travel
restrictions and stricter testing
requirements in many countries there are
confirmed cases in many countries now
including at least seven here in canada
in bc alberta ontario and quebec yet
there remain more questions than answers
about this new variant and how much of a
threat it really is eric sorenson looks
at what we know and don't know
in canada only a few omicron cases have
been detected but it's enough that
ottawa is asking the national advisory
committee on immunization for updated
guidance on booster shots whether we
should revise national standards
national attitudes and actions on the
use of boosters across canada in the
context of the new
omicron
variant it has some canadians thinking
twice about their holiday plans i
literally just talked to my in-laws last
night and we said you know what let's
revisit this in a week if there is a
surge in covid cases it will be met by
something that didn't exist a year ago a
wall of vaccinations around most of the
community it's not an impenetrable wall
but it's still a wall the head of
moderna one of the biggest vaccine
producers says omicron's many mutations
may render vaccines less effective given
the large number of mutations it is
highly possible at the efficacy of a
vaccine all of them is going down but
pfizer is still bullish on the current
regimen this
drug
works for all known mutations including
the omegran one infectious disease
experts agree the current vaccines are
working we're not seeing the
catastrophic
situations now where
the hospital beds are
are about to exceed capacity so and i
think a lot of that is because of the
vaccination it could take a few weeks
before scientists determine whether new
vaccine boosters are needed or would
help the aim the task at hand is to
delay the dominance of the variant in
canada as long as we can we just need to
get ready and face the music
once omicron becomes dominant we
probably need to intensify our response
a bit that could mean wearing masks more
often or reducing capacity again in
crowded places still canadians are
better protected this winter and
jeanette purser will take advantage of
that we didn't see our daughter
and her family last year it broke my
heart so we're really excited about it
this year
everybody in our family who can be
vaccinated has been vaccinated and
getting vaccinated say scientists
remains by far the best protection erik
sorensen global news toronto
the true extent of the spread of the
omicron variant is unclear what is clear
is that cases are turning up almost
everywhere now 13 were reported in
england today and the uk is launching a
new campaign for booster shots as
crystal commansing reports the head of
the who says the emergence of this
variant exposes the need for global
vaccine equality
with a new variant of concern spreading
vaccination centers will once again be
the uk's front line of defense
the target that we've set ourselves
is to offer a booster to everyone
eligible
by the end of january
[Music]
the uk was the first western nation to
start vaccinating its citizens against
the pandemic virus nearly a year later
every adult in the u.k is being
encouraged to get a third covit 19 shot
given the mammoth scope of the
initiative the military is being asked
to help out once again what we're doing
is taking some proportionate
precautionary measures while our
scientists crack the omicron code while
there are many unknowns when it comes to
this new strain the head of the world
health organization says cracking the
code of this pandemic is not a mystery
it's about equitable access to vaccines
countries in the south of africa have
reported the majority of cases with the
new strain
not surprising given the continent as a
whole has a vaccination rate of around
just seven percent
the virus is a ruthless opportunist and
the inequity that has characterized the
global response
has now come home to roost new
restrictions have been implemented
around the world after omicron was
identified on november 24th by south
african researchers but no one really
knows for sure when the mutation started
circulating
the netherlands traced a case going back
to november 19th and scotland traced a
case back to the 20th i think a lot of
people are worried particularly in the
run-up to christmas and you know worried
about the implications and obviously
everyone wants to be able to travel meet
family and things like that boris
johnson says vaccine clinics will start
popping up like christmas trees around
the uk
and for now there's no plans for a
lockdown
crystal gamansen global news
london
two other important notes about travel
canadians taking a trip to the u.s
that's less than 72 hours long no longer
need a negative pcr test to re-enter the
country the relaxed rules apply to fully
vaccinated canadian citizens permanent
residents people registered under the
indian act children under 12 and those
with a medical exemption to the vaccine
travelers will still need to show proof
of vaccination and proper id
and starting today unvaccinated
canadians over the age of 12 won't be
able to abort a plane or passenger train
in canada the grace period for the
policy which took effect october 30th
has now expired a negative covid19 test
will also no longer serve as a
substitute for vaccination
now to british columbia where heavy rain
is falling again tonight for the third
time in a week an atmospheric river is
drenching southwestern b.c where
flooding and landslides have already
disrupted the lives of thousands of
people it has been the wettest fall ever
recorded in the pacific northwest
rainfall records were broken in many
places including vancouver and
abbotsford and it's not over the red on
this map shows rainfall warnings in
effect on bc's south and central coast
this storm may not have the same level
as intensity as we saw mid-month in some
of our hardest hit areas such as the
fraser valley
but the cumulative effect of this
succession of storms will be and
continues to be a major challenge
in abbotsford in the fraser valley
farmers already flooded once in the
sumas prairie area are watching the
water rise again that's where our
heather yorick's west is tonight heather
donna it has been a very busy day for
already exhausted city crews and
residents with localized flooding today
along the trans-canada highway through
abbotsford as well as onto farmlands of
both the sumas and matt suite prairies a
number of buildings and homes have had
to be evacuated today as this community
deals with heavy rain once again
the tractor and some muddy oars when the
sumas prairie was flooded nearly two
weeks ago it was the only way ed friesen
could get around his farm the flow of
water would actually it was so strong
you couldn't stand up it would take you
away but instead of cleaning up the
poultry and blueberry farmer is bracing
for yet another storm well we sandbagged
the barns the back doors
we got all the equipment on high ground
this time
and
yeah this is water from the nooksack
river that is now making its way into
the sumas prairie adding to the burden
of waterlogged farmers who are desperate
for things to start drying out so they
can clean up
and this water is largely from last
weekend's storm there is still more rain
to come with another atmospheric river
now bearing down on the region this
event is
very strong it's the third consecutive
storm in a week with very little respite
in between these events
so the effects are cumulative snow melt
is also a component of this event and
will add to the storm totals of rain
into the rivers and and creeks i am
optimistically uh hopeful that
we're going to get through this round
three
abbotsford's mayor says so far local
infrastructure including a newly
repaired dike along the sumas river is
standing up against the pressure
hundreds of members of canada's armed
forces have also helped the city prepare
so the water was up to the sandbags
roughly a foot below the top layer which
is why we built the foot up and it's
doing the job it's supposed to but for
the flood weary the seemingly endless
rains are taking a toll it's
heartbreaking it's like is this going to
keep happening the poor farmers down
from us too the cows
how much can people take after a summer
of drought the region now experiencing
the wettest november it's ever seen
and these rains will continue overnight
into wednesday before there is finally a
break in the forecast officials hoping
then focus can turn to recovery donna
all right thanks heather the atmospheric
river is also heightening the risk of
avalanches the avalanche danger is now
high to extreme in mountainous regions
across much of b.c back-to-back weather
systems have left a huge accumulation of
snow at high elevations makes for great
skiing but rising temperatures and
extreme winds can also create perfect
avalanche conditions
the community of hope was completely cut
off by the catastrophic rain and
flooding over two weeks ago and now
major highways are closed again as a
precaution isolating hope for a second
time robin gill reports
brian mclean is counting on 500 sandbags
in case the river behind his home gets
the best of him i'm 72 years old and
you know that's my retirement package
the riverview neighborhood in hope bc
sits on the banks of the coquihalla
river it's pretty hard to determine the
rivers as high as it usually gets so you
know the 100 milliliters could really
cause some problems don't they know it i
don't want to see that water up
against my front door it got too close
the first time neal peterson barely
sleeps after flood waters rushed up to
his house two weeks ago i get up at
every two hours or so and
and i go walk down the river and see how
high it is see if it's going up or down
just to give you an idea of the extent
of the storm damage here in hope this is
a fellow road and it's not lost on the
people who live here that that's a
reference to a shakespearean tragedy
this may seem like it's the end of the
road but in fact
this road extended way beyond those
construction crews there was all this
land in between but the river now runs
through it hope is used to being a stop
for people traveling between the lower
mainland and the interior of british
columbia but the transcanada highway is
closed and hope is a ghost town that's
worrying the mayor businesses have
really taken ahead of course the
highways are open the highways are
closed highway one is the single most
important artery in the lower mainland
and when it's closed for an extended
period i know that it's difficult and
very challenging for people
but the main worry is protecting homes a
dozen are on evacuation alert
brian mclean and his friends managed to
clean up the mess from the last time
i've already had my house flooded once
and for him
that's enough
robin gill global news hope bc
coming up the pandemic's tragic impact
on people who didn't have covet 19.
we know the pandemic has strained
canada's health care system and a new
report from the canadian medical
association puts it into perspective
thousands of canadians died from covid19
but the report found thousands of others
died from delays getting treatment
abigail beeman explains
i'm at the bitter end here i've been
hanging by a thread for a while
fighting kidney failure since 2018
pandemic backlogs mean jessica bailey is
still waiting for a transplant in a lot
of pain with less than one percent
kidney function
it scares me to be honest in my position
you know um
as a palliative patient they say they
give you about a year
and if we're backlogged more than a year
then i mean my odds aren't very good
scared by the findings of a new report
with a sobering headline more than 4 000
excess deaths due to delayed care
unrelated to covid and that only covers
the period between august and december
2020. i don't know what else we need to
do to make it more clear that we can't
just focus on the pandemic laura
harilock is an icu doctor who has seen
her share of culved but also too many
chronic illness cases left untreated she
calls heartbreaking didn't or couldn't
access care or too afraid to access care
who come in with a very acute
complication of that illness that could
have been prevented
but ultimately
an acute complication that took their
life
in ontario in-person visits plunged for
diseases including congestive heart
failure and diabetes at the start of the
pandemic nowhere near normal levels by
january really getting a sense of how
bad the health system was impacted
really actually was quite shocking the
report warns correcting the problem will
take years and cost at least 1.3 billion
dollars to return wait times to
pre-pandemic levels by next june
that's just for eight surgeries
including cataracts and hip replacements
with more than three hundred thousand
people waiting the health minister
pointed to campaign promises committing
to address the issue and said the total
number of delayed surgeries is actually
much higher there would be approximately
780 thousand
delayed surgeries in canada at this
particular time the actual impact is
much broader than that so the 1.3
billion dollars to get us back on track
i think is really just a starting point
of what is needed for the system
saskatchewan just resumed organ
transplants yet is still impacted by
staffing shortages
becoming part of that statistic is scary
the delay means jessica bailey's live
donor is no longer a match she's now
looking for another with o positive
blood
abigail beeman global news ottawa
vaccinating public servants in canada
ahead how many are still refusing the
shot
you're watching global national
[Music]
covet-19 vaccine mandates are now in
place across this country in nova scotia
this is the last day for some employees
to prove their vaccination status newly
released information from three
provinces shows the majority of
provincial employees are following the
terms of government vaccine mandates but
thousands of others are not as ross lord
explains that's despite extensions to
deadlines and a softening of hard-line
positions
their union says all of these front-line
health care workers are fully vaccinated
as they rally for better wages and
working conditions but for some others
it's deadline day to either get their
shots or be sent home without pay i'm
sure there are some people that going
there are going to be going off as of
today on
administrative leave the nova scotia
government isn't saying how many
provincial employees are refusing covet
19 vaccines and are off the job it does
say there might be some disruption to
school busing nova scotia says 99
percent of provincial employees have at
least one dose of the vaccine
elsewhere british columbia says 98 of
its workers are partially or fully
vaccinated although 432 employees are
not or have not revealed their status
alberta says 96 of health care workers
are fully immunized but that leaves a
sizable number of holdouts it is
disappointing that about 3 000
of our staff have either not submitted
proof of vaccination
or have decided to remain unvaccinated
and alberta is backing off from some
employees introducing rapid testing at
locations where forcing unvaccinated
employees off the job would undermine
health care services i do not want to
see services in any community reduced
because staff are unable to work quebec
and ontario have already softened their
hard-line positions with a prolonged
stare down between health authorities
and holdouts some of whom threatened to
launch legal challenges under the
canadian charter of rights and freedoms
the real question is will it likely
succeed and there i think at the end of
the day the answer is no resistance
won't stop there the country's largest
healthcare union is open to filing
grievances on behalf of some
unvaccinated members we don't assume
that the position of government or
employer is always the right position
more decisions to come about vaccine
policies as the pandemic drags on
ross lord global news halifax
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is quebec city getting festive
for the season we'd love to see your
canada especially merry and joyful
pictures from the places you love send
them to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you